[Musica]
Buonasera a tutti
prima di parlare di bellezza vi do un
dato negli ultimi 20 anni sono andati
via dal sud Italia 2 milioni di persone
e sono persone spesso le più qualificate
le più giovani le più motivate vedo in
sala tanti ragazzi e mi verrebbe da fare
anche con loro il gioco che faccio
spesso quando vado nelle scuole dico
alzi la mano chi se ne vuole andare Le
devo dire che quasi sempre più della
metà delle mani si alzano per dire me ne
voglio andare Sapete qual è la capitale
dell'esodo in Sicilia in Italia e se non
ha perso il primato negli ultimi anni
anche in Europa è una cittadina che si
chiama provincia di Agrigento che non so
chi ha visitato di voi è una cittadina
piena di bellezza dove c'è un palazzo
del principe con un borremans che in
qualsiasi altra città capace
valorizzarsi sarebbe un attrattore
importante ricordo sono stata
recentemente al Cenacolo di Leonardo a
Milano dove ho fatto due mesi d'attesa
per andarci e poi si cammina sui passi
di Pirandello e la cittadina dove
Pirandello ambientato tante delle sue
novelle dite Ma perché parto da questo
quando dobbiamo parlare di bellezza
perché
gran parte di questi ragazzi vanno via
per perché non vedono di fronte a se
stessi Altro che due strade che sono la
fuga o il fallimento Ecco noi da 17 anni
ormai lavoriamo in Sicilia per dire a
questi ragazzi che oltre alla fuga al
fallimento c'è una terza via parola che
ricorda ne parlava Berlinguer tutt'altro
contesto della terza via la terza via è
restare costruire e sperare e quindi
veniamo proprio a Che cos'è viene tesori
oggi ci sono
venti città 60 Borghi quindi piccoli
comuni della Sicilia è uno spin off
Mantova quindi in Lombardia che
partecipano a questa grande festa
collettiva che si svolge ogni anno ormai
tra agosto e novembre i luoghi vengono
intanto Censiti studiati messi a rete
digitalizzati
raccontati chiese palazzi collezioni
Giardini monasteri vecchie fabbriche
laboratori artigianali perché a noi non
interessa la bellezza per la bellezza la
funzione estetica della Bellezza I
luoghi hanno senso quando hanno un
racconto e nella nostra storia racconto
sempre che il luogo più visto della
storia ormai
Antica da 17 anni Abbiamo cominciato nel
2006 di via dei tesori non è un palazzo
sfolgorante è il rifugio antiaereo della
Seconda Guerra Mondiale che si trova
sotto il municipio di Palermo dove
all'apertura abbiamo visto una coda che
non so chi di voi conosce Palermo
arrivava quasi un chilometro di coda
perché era un luogo che raccontava
ciascuno un pezzo della propria storia
venivano gli ultimi anziani che Quelle
bombe le avevano vissute siamo qui nella
città che quest'anno celebrerà
l'ottantesimo dallo sbarco Quanta vita
c'è dentro questi avvenimenti della
grande storia che sono anche avvenimenti
della storia singole Ma venivano i figli
Venivano i nipoti venivano tenendo per
mano i loro vecchi ecco
attorno a questi luoghi che vengono
messi a rete pensate sono ormai 500 c'è
un'esplosione di attività come un
lievito che si spande sul territorio e
che fa emergere tutte le sue risorse
quindi
tour
voli in Piper dai vecchi aeroporti ma
turdi degustazione Tutto quello che un
territorio sa e può esprimere
questo oggi viene tesori Anzi devo dire
che questi sono i dati dell'anno scorso
quest'anno Comunque sono 300 circa 300
partner pubblici privati vedete
quest'anno c'è anche Gela perché non
voglio come dire ma ormai è abbastanza
si è già detto che anche jaila
quest'anno entrerà a far parte del
nostro circuito e poi sono quest'anno 20
città siciliane e circa 60 Borghi vedete
una grande Sicilia punteggiata di
bellezza e di racconto di bellezza e
animata da
1200 ragazzi che questi luoghi li
raccontano vedete viene tesori nasce nel
2006 all'Università di Palermo
per celebrare il bicentenario
dell'università Io ricordo benissimo
quando il rettore dell'epoca mi chiese
di organizzare un progetto e io pensai
che oltre ai seminari a tutto quello che
gli accademici giustamente fanno sarebbe
stato interessante aprire le porte delle
istituzioni di un'istituzione culturale
come l'università purtroppo in Italia ma
non soltanto in Italia c'è un grande
problema delle istituzioni culturali e
del mondo culturale in assoluto che è
quello di parlare a se stessi di non
pensare che la cultura può essere uno
straordinario lievito Democratico può
essere una leva di sviluppo una leva di
sviluppo inclusiva una leva di sviluppo
fondamentale e una leva di sviluppo
economico Perché adesso vi dirò che cosa
genera nei territori Questa è la
scommessa dei piccoli quando due anni fa
in pieno covid
quasi casualmente abbiamo chiesto a
piccoli comuni di partecipare al
progetto ne servivano tre in
quell'occasione e ne sono saliti a bordo
prima dieci poi venti Poi trenta poi 40
poi 50 abbiamo capito che era stata una
bellissima restituzione per noi ma
abbiamo anche capito quanto questo
network fosse prezioso e abbiamo
costituito con loro un'associazione che
si chiama associazione Borghi dei tesori
ed è stata una scoperta incredibile
Perché vedete questi territori spopolati
invecchiati dove i ragazzi fuggono sono
scrigni incredibili di bellezza E di
storia e lì abbiamo scoperto luoghi che
noi stessi siciliani che lavoriamo a
questo progetto da tanti anni Non
immaginavamo neanche penso alle miniere
penso ai Castelli penso alle
Torri penso a questi luoghi che
sostanzialmente dalla fine della società
contadina sono stati abbandonati perché
arrivarci spesso è una scommessa
guardare lo stato delle strade e che
però sono luoghi straordinariamente
interessanti
Eccoci Che cosa succede a questi luoghi
vengono
Resi fruibili in modo trasversale perché
vedete al cittadino al visitatore non
importa molto che un luogo sia della
regione del comune dell'università di
un'associazione
il visitatore Vuole trovare città aperte
raccontate fruibili trasversalmente
questi nostri luoghi si visitano pensate
con un unico strumento e un coupon
digitale che ha un QR code che come una
carta d'imbarco consente di visitare
trasversalmente i luoghi per prossimità
geografiche o anche per tematismo i
Liberty l'arabo Normanno i luoghi della
guerra i luoghi degli ebrei e tutte le
altre suggestioni pensate che a Palermo
dove il progetto ormai esiste da 17 anni
ed è molto radicato nell'ultima edizione
abbiamo aperto circa 150 luoghi abbiamo
realizzato circa
100 tour e altrettante esperienze
Ecco io credo
e lo dico qua mi tolgo Tolgo i panni di
Presidente delle vie dei tesori e torno
a quelli di giornalista che è il mio
primo mestiere è ancora attuale mestiere
c'è un grande deficit di racconto del
nostro Sud il nostro sud e lo dico anche
perché faccio la corrispondente di un
giornale nazionale è molto difficile
esportare storie che non abbiano ormai
una come dire un recinto in cui il
nostro Sud viene percepito e raccontato
c'è un Sud produttivo creativo non
assistito orgoglioso di gente che fa
cose bellissime a questo abbiamo
dedicato il nostro ultimo progetto che
si chiama ho scelto il sud abbiamo
censito 300 storie di ritorno di gente
che è tornata proprio un controcanto
all'esodo di cui tanto si parla abbiamo
girato 50 video e le stiamo portando
adesso nelle scuole nelle intensità per
dire che si può che quel peccato che
Tomasi di Lampedusa chiamava il peccato
di fare il peccato che i siciliani non
perdonano a nessuno tanto meno a se
stessi quello di fare perché fare
significa togliere l'alibi a chi non fa
Quindi è un peccato gravissimo di cui ci
si macchia Ecco costruzione di comunità
prima che ai turisti parliamo ai
cittadini che si riprendono i loro
luoghi si riprendono la loro storia si
riprendono le loro radici e si
riprendono il proprio valore Community
building
Ecco anche qui
la cultura non è Elite perché dobbiamo
parlare un linguaggio che non è
comprensibile tutto può essere mediato
in modo Anzi parlare semplice e
bellissimo tutti i grandi parlano in
modo semplice e conviene tesori come
vedete la cultura diventa un bisogno di
massa
il popolo delle vie dei tesori non è
soltanto quello degli accademici dei
professori o dei turisti è il popolo il
popolo sono
impiegati
operai e insegnanti ogni genere di di
cittadino ogni tipo di cittadino viene a
partecipare a questa grande festa
portare la cultura in strada farla
uscire dalle accademie farla parlare
farla diventare viva è la forza dello
storytelling anche qui Torno al mio
primo mestiere un luogo muto
È un luogo in cui entriamo ammiriamo per
qualche istante la bellezza ma non ci
dice nulla un luogo raccontato tutti i
luoghi delle vie dei tesori sono luoghi
raccontati da mediatori culturali È un
luogo che invece è in grado di
trasmettere quel che è nel mosaico della
città quindi la forza dello storytelling
quante volte abbiamo visto che è un
rudere bella storia è più interessante
più attrattivo di un palazzo sfolgorante
che la sua storia non la racconta
ogni visitatore il protagonista vi
raccontavo dei dei nipoti e dei figli di
chi la guerra l'aveva vissuta Ma ricordo
anche quando a Palermo Abbiamo aperto il
deposito dove c'erano le prime sigarette
Ecco si sono riaccese le luci ricordate
quasi almeno un teatro alla Carmen anche
a Palermo ma anche a Catania c'era una
fabbrica di sigarette dove le donne
hanno fatto le loro prime conquiste era
un mondo che per la prima volta si
apriva al lavoro femminile sapete Quanti
visitatori sono venuti a portare
fotografie a portare storie di vita
quindi questo racconto collettivo questo
laboratorio collettivo che
trasforma le città è un racconto
partecipato da ciascuno dei nostri
visitatori vi dicevo
400.000 un assalto all'arma bianca nel
2019 poi siamo stati tra i pochissimi
coraggiosi Nel 2020 e nel 2021 a portare
questa Lucina una sorpresa in tempi di
covi dobbiamo stato difficilissimo
capite bene era difficile già tenere
aperta una scuola pensate quanto fosse
difficile stipulare protocolli sanitari
per ogni singolo luogo di 500 luoghi
diversi ovviamente anche dal punto di
vista economico molto difficile molto
meno sostenibile però abbiamo tenuta
accesa una luce e questo è stato
bellissimo siamo tornati nel 2022 con
circa 280.000 visitatori
questo che cosa Che cosa genera Ecco un
progetto come vi dicevo nato per la
comunità dalla comunità perché sapete
molti pensano che via dei tesori cos'è è
la regione e la sovrintendenza e
l'università in cui c'è da cui siamo
nati come startup no vi siete tesori è
la scommessa di un gruppo di
professionisti alcuni andati via è
tornati come me altri in Sicilia che
hanno
appunto scommesso sulla loro sulla loro
terra e tutto questo oggi è diventato
oltre che un progetto di comunità un
grande attrattore turistico quest'anno
abbiamo ricevuto dal ministero dei beni
culturali lencomi al premio del
paesaggio siamo tra le poche
manifestazioni di Massimo interesse
turistico della Regione Siciliana e come
Vedete qui la miopia non mi aiuta ma il
circa il 60%
il 67% Se non ricordo male dei
visitatori viene a Palermo perché questi
sono Questo è uno studio di queste
schermate fatto soltanto su Palermo per
il festival e quindi diciamo è diventato
anche un trattore l'impatto economico
che cosa genera la volontà di un gruppo
di amici e ce ne sono tanti qui in sala
che sono venuti oggi con me quest'anno
l'impatto economico è stato di 6,3
milioni di euro e l'impatto
occupazionale è di equivale a 85 posti
di lavoro generati
per finire un progetto sostenibile
Come si finanzia questo progetto in
minima parte con fondi pubblici che
proviamo a intercettare spesso
partecipando a bandi circolari e tutte
le opportunità che ci sono che è un
lavoro anche quello è un lavoro che
toglie tante energie rispetto alla
garanzia Insomma costante poi si
finanzia con sponsor privati che ormai
sono diventati veramente tanti ma si
finanzia soltanto con il piccolo
contributo che i visitatori versano per
ogni visita o per ogni attività che
fanno contributi che sono peraltro
contributi liberali perfino
detraibili dalla dichiarazione dei
redditi Ecco questi piccoli contributi
però consentono di tenere in piedi una
manifestazione quello che accenno e
l'appello che faccio a tutti sempre gli
amministratori tutti coloro che
gestiscono i luoghi non fate mai nulla
gratis nulla che famiglia gratis perché
la gratuità non lo dico io ma lo dico
ormai i più autorevoli studi nel settore
e non è assolutamente svalutante non è
incentivante non non dà valore a quel
che si fa e non produce nessun economia
e costruire speranza Ecco torno
a quello che dicevamo all'inizio no
pensavamo vide tesori non sono partita
dal dal patrimonio Sono partita dai dati
di Esodo dei nostri dei nostri ragazzi
che cosa direi se oggi dicesse mi
chiedessero Che cosa è via dei tesori
che tutti percepiscono come un grande
progetto di valorizzazione Prima di
tutto è una semina di speranza e mi
piace chiudere sempre con questa
immagine che molti di voi Anzi Immagino
tutti conoscerete era Don Puglisi
parroco ucciso a Brancaccio il 15
settembre del 1993 lui diceva
e se ognuno fa qualcosa allora si può
fare molto e noi ci muoviamo sul suo
solco Grazie
[Applauso]